[Music]
foreign
hey y'all
WC here uh Michael checklist came on the
podcast to talk about uh our show we did
a television show called the accused
it's on Fox uh coming out January 22nd
[Music]
reading people
people it's my job
and my read is
caught up in a bad situation
court is now in session will the
defendant please rise
you can tell me
you can tell me the truth
Ingrid was a very smart girl you will
find him the only way we get Justice is
by getting it ourselves
what if he does what I'm afraid of but
my God tells me that he will do
we're not here today to second guess
what he didn't do or should have done
we're here because of what he actually
did
has the jury reached a verdict
have a legal system the legal system did
nothing
don't say that
I did what I did because I had to
[Music]
we all make mistakes
follow us
we had such an amazing conversation this
is only this is the second time this has
happened in the history of the good for
you pod
where
um I wanted to break it into two parts
this is part one I want to tell you
something about this Thug that I'm that
is in my home
um I was able to kind of ascertain and I
think you know this that you descended I
didn't know you had Spartan ancestry but
he walked out on my deck and within four
minutes a hawk flew by and like
basically landed on his shoulder landed
on the tree above us yeah but that was
you it didn't land near me it was just
like my my Leader's here what do you
need from me and then I've I've seen
this but it was when I was alone it then
Dove down and to grab something to grab
something I don't know if you got it or
not but he or she I don't know but I
think the female Hawks hunt but maybe
the males too
I'm sure that and I'm a bit of a bird
watcher but uh
let's find out about that yeah first of
all the great Michael checklist is here
everybody and he needs no introduction
so I'm not going to
um uh do it because uh if you need an
introduction you're lazy you can Google
him you already know who he is first of
all you're going wait I know wait okay
the shield Fantastic Four what's the uh
spirited in do that on your I'm not
going to take care of you or uh that
like it's not my job to babysit the
credits you want me to say right now
because use the Googles use by the way
how about duckduck go I'll do you one
better because if you use the Google's
the first 12 searches I couldn't even
find your birthday it was like you
Google someone now and there's like nine
like buy this in Progressive Insurance
and then the olden time you have to
describe it's like you know so go to
DuckDuckGo maybe but also it'll be in
the bio like there's this thing now
where people are that are getting free
content demand that you provide the free
content the way they want it and I'm not
going to let you youngins I'm not gonna
enable you well I'm going to provide a
little adversity I like that so because
Guess what at your job you're not going
to be able to go ask your boss hey I
don't know who this guy is can you help
me and they're gonna be like you're
fired
so it's a lot of times a younger
generation it's your guys's job to go
find the answers before you ask the
person who hired you and can fire you go
figure it out how about this
thank me later I like it you're gonna
think I'm a bitch now but thank me later
so now they're just going can you let
him talk our hero
so how did I get so lucky to have you
sitting across from me this is surreal
we finally have something uh that we
have in common that we've done a show we
finally have something where you're
contractually obligated to do that no no
I'm actually not I'm not you know that
no but really honestly I I'm I'm only in
the pilot episode of this show and I
directed a show and I have no further
obligation to this and really it the
reason I'm here a twofold first of all
you I've been a fan for a long time and
I you've made us laugh a lot in my house
my daughter is a comedy writer so she
adores you I can't wait to meet her when
it like makes sense right yeah
absolutely and I'm dying to have her on
the podcast and we'll do that when it
makes sense yeah just uh you know a
truly funny woman and as a woman as a
young woman my my daughter really looks
up to you and admires you so I
that you like to watch me but okay yeah
no fine and and then there's Howard
Gordon and that sort of uh brings us
both together and Howard Gordon is the
you know I think it's interesting
because we are maybe for the first time
in the in the history of television
please correct me if I'm wrong I'm kind
of a history of Television nerd um for
the first time it's almost like the
showrunners uh uh or what you guys might
think of as like creators
um I tend to like talk to the audience
because I hate it when people just like
say things that are they are they're
almost the bigger celebrities than
famous actors sometimes at this point
because you're because audiences have
been burned like actors I really love
I've gone to see them and then they've
been in a bad movie but it's not the
actor's fault so now it's like sometimes
boy do I know that feeling
you know what I mean so then they go why
did why did Chiclets look why did why
was he in that horrible movie or whoever
it is why was Whitney in that movie's
like dude I didn't write it it was good
when I signed up also this practicality
you know I mean about people who say
yeah that you know I'm raising two
children you know sometimes something
pays the bills also and I needed
something that changed also something
something that happens a lot with regard
to work is you know you everything looks
good on paper the the right people are
involved and then you show up and day
one you realize this is a shit show and
this isn't going to work out this is
going to work out for reasons completely
had nothing to do with you and this
isn't your fault and we're not blaming
any of the Productions you and I have
both been on but a lot of times because
oh I am okay
I'm not going to do that I'm kidding
Josh probably someone named you know
what I mean it's like I feel like I
could guess then I could guess half the
men's names that like first name
certainly that made bad shows that you
were on because cause it's just like
they're all the same it's Josh it's Dave
it's all just Harvard guys that think
they're smart and they're not and they
trust they don't have any adversity
because they went to Harvard and uh
where Epstein had an office for 20 years
but who cares um and also some people
get ahead of themselves you know I
remember doing a a movie with a
first-time director and he had written a
very good script pulled together a
really good cast and on day one we're
standing there and we realized very
quickly oh this guy's never been on a
set never mind directed anything I know
he's a first timer but he he doesn't
know how to set up a shot sure and
that's terrifying when you go like holy
shit this guy which then gets tricky
because the cinematographer you know and
then on top of it they saddled him with
a cinematographer who had only done
music videos oh well that's criminal so
that was just bad over bad and then you
just go next door I in the ca I went
next door to the bookstore and bought a
ton of books and I said sat there and
read books and went you know I'm gonna
hit my mark say my words always give 100
of myself because no flies on me but
holy shit this is gonna be a nightmare
and the thing that gets even more
confusing when I when I you know because
to me I take people's time very
seriously as an Entertainer you know as
a comedian it's like when people come to
see you yeah they're paying 80 you make
them laugh or you know that's for like
uh let's say Vegas or something but like
they got a babysitter they got it to
drink minimum by the time you get in it
might be 200 can I turn the tables on
you and ask you some questions you can
physically turn this table on top of me
it might be the only way to get me to
shut up no but let me let me ask you a
couple of questions because I'm
interested and I don't know okay uh I
don't know how you got into stand up
because stand-up fascinates me because I
did a little bit of it back in the day
when I was on the precipice of getting
the role of Belushi in in wired I
thought it was just like a rite of
passage as a man in Boston well yeah you
know I've been in Boston I had to you
know I had to do it performed at the
comedy connection with Naruto I came up
through the through the acting thing you
know I went to Boston University School
of Fine Arts there I started I helped
well you know listen I was I was a fly
on the wall and a helper as a 14 year
old
when a mentor of mine opened an equity
theater in Lowell Massachusetts when I
was 14 years old that's how I Got My
Equity card and and that all the the
dramatic acting side of it was always
sort of my focus and everything but I
love doing comedy and I did a lot of
comedic plays as a kid did you entertain
your parents yeah well that's how it
started I mean I was five years old
there was that show the copycats with
Frank Ocean and Rich Little so my first
invitations were of them imitating
people and was it to get your parents to
La like did you wanna I found that I
could do it you know watch them
mimicking people and all of a sudden I
turn to my huge Greek family and go hey
I've seen better faces on an iodine
bottle and they would crack up laughing
and I was like hey that little did I
stopped you there and I don't mean to
interrupt it's just that being able to
mimic is such an incredible gift and I'm
not trying to give you like be unjust
with you it's just I'm fascinated
because like Jimmy Fallon also I I it's
a muscular thing and an inner ear thing
because you have to be able to hear most
of us can't hear ourselves so we can't
judge whether our mimicry matches it
means you can hear them and yourself
mimics have a great ear but they also
understand where where other people put
the sound in their resonators right if
different places where you know uh like
there's 25 different imitations that are
basically centered in the same part in
the hard palate and by that I mean
whether you're doing Kermit the Frog
unbelievable but there's like so many
different
imitations that are in the same area you
know
um uh
shooby-dooby knows uh uh Sammy Davis Jr
is in the very same area and I've heard
other mimics say this you know you find
out where and there resonators people
makes up you know Truman Capote in here
because I would try to use my my vote my
you know okay this is going to be more
nasal because you know how sound moves
through air moves through a person's you
know how it moves to their imaginators
through their mouths but all my
imitations are old they're they're from
that period because I stopped being a
mimic when I fell in love with acting
which was very young but a lot of the
people if you were to mimic anyone in
the last 20 years they were just
mimicking those people actually all the
times
my newest one is what's her name you
know I love her oh my God I just I say
why
do you know these gays I don't listen
they're trying to kill me
she's so real good brilliant a green
Marjorie Taylor green the gays are
trying to kill us one last night
Coolidge
Coolidge oh she was in two bird girls so
good I love that she's killing it well
she's our Rodney Dangerfield yeah yeah
but now
he got it at 60. ladybug you know what I
mean and then Natural Born uh Natural
Born Killers it just genius you
understand that I'm not I'm not
criticizing young actors like they're
there's great ones out there they're
still making their bones Shia LaBeouf
and whatever but you can only uh deliver
so many emotions if you've only
experienced so many and I think just I
just get so excited seeing someone like
Jennifer Coolidge who was you know just
went from sitcom to sitcom making all
this money but no one got to see her
like let loose and do drama and I think
you know and I I sorry to jump around
that's a fact you know I mean because
sitcoms I did a sitcom first and
experience killed me okay really killed
me because people go the hardest thing
in the world is what to do stand up talk
in front of people right and then they
have you do a sitcom and they go well
this sucks because I hear a laugh track
it is acting on a sitcom is so hard
for a couple reasons but then everyone
thinks you're not a good actor right
because it's theater you're doing
theater right right it is you're
strapped there's only so much Behavior
you can do number one because of like
continuity and how many lines you have
so you can't be like eating an apple
doing it Brad Pitt is always eating in
every movie it's a very particular form
you can't be eating because like because
then live you have the props person
running in another tea and you're live
so you can't really also they don't
people don't realize you know you do a
reading on Monday and go home you do a
reading and maybe put it on its feet on
Tuesday and you go home Wednesday
there's a ton of changes
oh that's right that's different I mean
you're the 800 pound gorilla in that
situation because let's face it the show
Runners king or queen and uh and I was
you know 27 you know it was my first
show so it doesn't matter I'm not trying
to get sympathy because to me this feels
so similar to your Belushi thing and
when I heard about your Belushi thing I
was like oh my God you and I both and by
the way not complaining because here we
are we're carry drug you remember carry
strugg in the Olympics she had a broken
ankle and in order to win she had to do
the back yeah
on a broken ankle and hopping the smile
on her face re-broke her ankle that was
already broken heroic moment that's what
we do we go I don't need I I'm uh I'm
behind and you guys like I got like uh
we don't do like horse racing it's abuse
always always but let me just use this
uh metaphor which is we're both race
horses that as soon as they shot the gun
out the door jamb oh yeah and then
everyone so
the circumstances outside of my control
certainly completely like no but way
outside control
comically
uh like you always have to laugh about
it I mean it's like he was so you're so
talented that you got the role to play
Belushi
um not John right not John I'm sorry not
Jim sorry I'm trying to make a joke not
Jim because I would like to now make the
Jim Belushi movie that's kind of
interesting to me but because now he's
grown weed he all I mean all friendly
after all these years which I'm glad
about I'm really glad I was going to ask
because the only people that I really
really cared that because I wanted them
to know that I I never meant any harm I
don't think anyone thought that except
it was just a guilt by association right
it was like when something's hurtful to
you anybody and any anyone involved in
it is sort of and I understand that
mentality a bit although a lot of the
aggression was misplaced at the time but
I think it's important that people know
that when actors go to play uh because
actors just get so much shit because
everyone thinks we have like so much
money and we're like we like like you
actually have choice is in the matter
like people like yeah man uh you know
get get the shield reboot going on I'm
like
it's not up to me I have literally like
I it's not up to me nine business
Affairs people like would go to HR if I
even ask them about getting the rights
from Israel like that's how complicated
when you ask an actor I'm making up a
fake scenario how come you haven't made
the shield move I've noticed you do that
yes I do you but you're a writer your
brain goes into these creative places I
try to here's a scenario it's my job to
uh subtitle the Arcane way that we talk
to people that uh maybe don't understand
the business yet or because we we I'm
obsessed with uh in Show Business we
have the same we have link you know when
you get on a plane they just have a
whole different set of lingo that no one
uses Like You Stole Stow your luggage
you're like no one says Stow anywhere
but on a plane just put it in you mean
put our luggage in the thing there's a
lot of things that listen I'm from New
England I'm a practical mind I'm as
practical and pragmatic a human in this
industry as you'll ever meet I mean
there's a lot lot of very ethereal
people and and you know I'm there's a
reason I get cast is like the thing a
rock person right I get cast as a
literal as a rock you know it's an
actual yeah I'm very earthened and
grounded and practical minded in a lot
of ways but every bit an artist but I
can't help but sometimes Look at stupid
shit on a set and just go oh you know
there's a lot of things there's a
especially on big huge Behemoth movies
there's a lot of fat and unnecessary
stuff and and
there's things that drive me mad about
this business where it's it it moves
like the tectonic plates it's so slow
and I'm you know I'm an East Coast guy
like why are you doing this already can
I if I may I don't mean I don't mean to
interrupt I just want to say that like
I've spent so much time saying like
rejection in this business isn't
personal it's never personal because
I've been on the other side I've created
so many shows a lot of which selection
it's not rejection yeah so I've had
maybe five Pilots made HBO Amazon
whatever that didn't go for a Litany of
reasons it doesn't matter I'm glad they
didn't but I spent so much time as an
actor too that auditioned so much and
just you know it's not personal and I
would sit in the after an actor would
come in I would be like hey that was the
most beautiful like I am in all of you I
could never do what you just did you're
not getting this job for reasons
completely out of your control like it's
an Essence thing the network wants this
and this but you deserve this job and
you're not going to get it and here's
why and we will work together again and
can I please get your like all I want to
work with you again but and I'm also
like because
that person also did spend a week on
that audition oh yeah one of the
greatest lessons I ever learned was when
I became a director when I uh one of the
first sessions I I did a casting session
on the shield was uh I think the second
season of The Shield I directed an
episode and uh there was this one role
for a guest starred really heavy role
and I think 20 women came in and read
for this role and it it was
extraordinary because every one of them
came in and crushed it every single one
of them I could have hired any of them
uh and they would have killed it and
then it became about other things it
became about availability hi like how
they match up with the people that are
already cast all these other
you know sort of seeing by the way cost
I I don't mean to like money absolutely
no business yeah right yeah but I wanted
to I literally wanted to call every one
of them individually because I'm an
empath and I'm an actor and I and say to
them
you just you crushed it don't feel don't
take this as a rejection at all you keep
going you're amazing you killed it but
you know you don't have the time to do
that and it's also kind of like like
when I've had people do that to me I'm
like can you not tell me how close I was
because that makes sense for sure but
you knew on some way like okay don't now
like make this one that's why I didn't
do it I know because I'm like I want to
throw salt on it I would rather think I
like fucked up and like then I'll get
better but I think that for the longest
time I held that mentality and after
working with Howard Gordon who uh you
know was to Circle back I always do
Circle back believe it or not to the
tangents like I always get there and I'm
guessing and I'm still gonna show how by
the way your your work in accused is
really exceptional and I I want to say
that I saw a director's cut so it was a
rough cut there was no music music it
was temp music
but it wasn't about that it played and
the work was really really strong and
that's why I wrote to you it was like
you know this was very very strong and
you should know that I just wanted to
let you know like wow that's really
strong and I know that you know your
person who's primarily done I didn't
even know about the show running stuff
honestly I'm such an ignorant okay
forgive my ignorance it's just we get
caught up in our own worlds and
everything I know you as a stand-up
that's how I know you work the best
thing you can say to me that that you
know that's where I I became a fan of
yours and where you've made me laugh in
your specials over the years it's been a
long time I mean you've been doing
specials for many years
um so that's how I know you I didn't
even know about Two Broke Girls I I did
not know about that at all so you're
like an onion you just did so many
layers so I make people cry true ah boom
but if I see that I toss your love and
you whacked it I think we feel this um I
won't speak for you I feel like
compelled to like
help people feel feelings that they
wouldn't know about otherwise you know
what I mean so if for example like four
shows I would put it differently but I
know what you mean you know for me I my
sort of mission statement and I've said
it many times in the press and
interviews in other places but I'll say
it again because it really is what I'm
about
um
a long time ago it just I
this is the way I put it I don't want
for people to watch anything that I do
and they sort of removed way uh it's
important to me that I entertain you
first always that's the contract we have
with the audience yeah yeah I need to
entertain you but then I need I I really
want the trifecta which is to make you
think and feel
yeah if you know how it's a lot of times
we watch things and we're sort of almost
removed from it and then you sort of go
to the next thing I don't want that just
yeah I want to make someone stir inside
so you when you when someone sees a
picture of you because I've done this is
the kind of research I do is that I
before someone comes on especially of
your like ilk of uh Legend status person
I know you don't want it no like that's
how real Legends act you know I don't
want that of course you should you know
why it's the same thing it's like if
someone wants to run for president
they're automatically disqualified
because that's you know I mean if
someone doesn't want it I think it
should be by appointment like you know
my whole theory is we should just for
the president we should just find the
most well-run Costco in America no it's
so funny you say that because I I had a
concept for a a a television show some
years ago about a guy who uh is
appointed president who know what kind
of he he's he's a he's a guy he's a farm
something happens in his hometown and he
add and he said they uh uh local
reporters asked him something and he
says something so spot on and right on
that people are like who's this guy and
they start asking him and asking him and
next thing you know he's just being real
and saying what he's supposed to say
next thing you know people start to go
like this guy this guy and he's like
genius genius I don't want that but but
you should play that role it's just a
great idea of a of a on sort of an
unwilling here you're so reasonable
just being real and then they say Rises
to power
for the right reason for all the right
reasons and then people say well you
should run for office he goes no then I
don't want people for money and yeah I'm
not going to do that aren't they all
weirdos in there that like look that
like stock options and then they're like
well what do you think we should do
about this and he says it he's like well
I mean I think that we should X and that
people like
that's exactly reasonable and right next
thing you know the guy's the president
of the United States
um I'm writing on this which I very
gladly would he gets in he's like
hold on wasn't this built by slaves this
this White House yeah yeah maybe we
turned this into a museum
or something else and I can just kind of
live I don't really want to live here
because it's just like I just think that
over
recent history and I and I'm talking
about 35 plus years now we've watched
this sort of steady rise of the
fraudulent in the Craven
and I think that people are just were
they always there and we just didn't
have proof or well nobody here
maybe they were always there but I think
that it was harder
to rise to such prominence correct yes
agree and such to get your message out
there were checks and balances people
would identify you as being full of shit
and out you and then it would matter now
like you know there would be
consequences well now it becomes about
factionalism and what about isn't like
it doesn't matter like for my money I
don't care if you're a Republican or a
Democrat or whatever you are if you're
identified as a criminal fuck you yeah
yeah you know that's it that's it that's
it
really I think that I don't want to what
about ISM like if I find out that
someone who I voted for is is fucking up
and by the way I'm the person call me oh
call me disloyal and and then we'll stop
talking about voting but I think that
that this is such a uh breath of fresh
air for people to hear because I think
so many people are afraid to say that
especially in Hollywood because you're
like if I don't identify with a certain
party they're not gonna hire me or if I
say like I'm the person that when
election rolls around I genuinely even
though yes I voted a certain way in the
past but I'm definitely like well what
is it okay I'm still
like the person who's listening to both
sides trying to make sure that you know
this person is still they can't stop
listening yeah I mean that's the problem
we've stopped listening and we've
stopped talking I don't go I'm just
gonna vote for this guy because he's
wearing the color jersey of my team yeah
that's what's happened yeah and people
find all manner of reasons now I happen
to believe that the there is an
imbalance in terms of the egregiousness
of uh one side over the other and I'm
not even going to speak totally I think
it's totally obvious fine
um uh but but it's not to say that there
aren't plenty of people on both sides of
the aisle that are fucking up but I
think what I think what happens is when
someone like you know I played um Sports
you know I'm sure you played I did the
last words yeah what you do when you're
so to me I think politics has kind of
become Sports in a way a lot of ways
teams teams you know your team no matter
what and that's it and that that's very
American isn't it and then I'm loyal to
my team and and although it wasn't a
foul when you could the objectivity
isn't there it's like dude the guy but
here's past interference and you know it
and here's what happens like I I when
when the other team starts cheating okay
and the ref doesn't call it because he's
friends with the who cares why it
becomes about winning no matter what but
then the other team that's quote losing
to the cheaters they got to start just
playing their game if you want to win
historically so for me when we used to
play basketball if you're gonna put make
me have a technical foul on purpose then
then we gotta start playing that we're
talking about a return to honesty and
integrity and the problem with that is
to go I'm not going to play everybody
points out the fallibility in the other
person because no one's perfect and
people have fucked up in the past yeah
right so uh when you point out that
fallibility yeah no one can stand up and
say like I'm I'm completely
unimpeachable and without uh fault you
but but that doesn't mean mean it's like
saying you know I'm not going to brush
my teeth because they're just going to
get dirty anyway yeah can I do I make
the bed but exactly and I still have to
try the only reason the only the only
reason I'm bringing that like can I tell
you something that's my logic of why am
I gonna go stretch today because if I
don't stretch tomorrow like it's not
gonna have done anything like that same
lot we all do that on some level we're
like there's a very big difference
between someone who's who's made
mistakes and learns from them and
improves on upon themselves and moves
forward than someone who just goes ah
effort I'm I'm just gonna keep doing by
the way this is easy it's all about me
and I don't give a shit and I'm
comfortable so like why do I have to
think about the kids in the Cobalt mines
right we're the ones that are okay but
we're getting heavy here man I mean look
it's I'm just saying this is I see
myself in a way and I know this well
that's this is a perfect segue into
accused Sabrina's family hired a private
security firm that traced it to Devin's
IP address
this is uh this is a lot to take in
I I'm not quite sure how to react to
this
would help our assessment if you can
tell us about any Disturbing Behavior
I'm sorry what kind of assessment
this isn't the first time Devin's
Behavior has raised a flag so you're
expelling him
right I mean that's that's where this is
going isn't it
we'll save you the trouble
no we're going to pull Devin out of
school Lynn maybe we should hear them
out are you coming
and I'm sorry to tow the company line or
whatever but I'm I'm going to talk about
this the reason I was attracted to this
I had no intention of doing a a one-off
on a Anthology series it was because
Howard Gordon first of all wrote it yeah
genius super loser you know Howard
Gordon Homeland you know I say okay I'll
read this and sure enough I'm blown away
and I'm like yeah this is something I
want to do uh I I think this is really
smart and poignant you know what if I
may
doesn't have an agenda except to be
existential crises in in law so here we
have someone who's accused of of a of a
crime in the First Act and then we go
back and show the audience exactly
what's happened and then in the in the
last act you see what the verdict is
am I the only one who thinks we need to
talk about what happened
what were you thinking when you
threatened that girl what was I thinking
yes
I guess I was thinking she's a stuck-up
bitch who deserves whatever happens to
her
it's a great formula for of Television I
was on one of the episodes I was
watching uh Michael's episode I didn't
know how it was gonna end I'm in this
business I was literally with someone I
was like oh okay I don't know hold on I
know what it is I know what it is like I
literally was guessing either I was
guessing and I was like no that it
couldn't be this because and then I was
like this is what a really smart
showrunner would do so it's got to be
this and then I was still stunned at the
ending stunned yeah me too instead and
yours that I felt the same way I was
like oh you know I just I don't know it
was numb at the end of it and but not
none uh ride for real yeah you know and
that's the kind of stuff that you want
to be a part of stuff that actually has
an impact on people it felt to me a lot
like and I watched this during the
pandemic
um but your honor with uh um of course
oh my God Brian Cranston yeah where you
were like great Brian I don't know who
to be mad at no one like no one's done
anything wrong but everyone's just in a
it's being a real pickle well I think
that that that's why like during the the
time of the shield and the and and The
Sopranos it sort of brought on this
highly complex time rise of of the
anti-hero and now we've gone through
that period but now we're really delving
into human Frailty and the and the fact
of the matter is none of us
none of us is uh you know immune and and
this these are things issues that we
deal with in our lives and we feel uh we
see ourselves reflected on everyone has
a version of the problem in in your
episode even if it's not doesn't look
like that it still feels as it's not
precisely that but but it's like what I
say about actors no two actors has the
same trajectory right we have crossover
right right there's things that we have
in common different life experiences uh
in auditioning or whatever it is in the
process but your your path is completely
unique to your life and no one else has
your path and that and it's just
absolutely informs who you are why you
interact with the world the way you do
and the why you're such talent and it's
it's your sort of DNA on the business
you know that's what I love about it and
I wanna there's so many things I wanna
say so I'm gonna really try to like
Wrangle my OCD a little bit because I do
do me going into the show like the
decision to do it I think is just
interesting like actors work is like
fascinating to watch and so I'm watching
you do this and watching your work and
then I'm going the only thing that could
be as compelling is watching you do this
is get your uh line of thinking of why
you decided to do it that's just as
interesting to me
why a great actor thing itself because
for me it was so I was very well there's
another part of it too I don't get to
play this guy I don't get to play a
brain surgeon who's buttoned up
emotionally all my roles usually are
very gregarious over the top people or
or superheroes or or really powerful men
this is much more of a of a emotional
fragile yeah absolutely
high level of fragility and and and fear
someone's scared someone who's scared
right it threw my wife a lot she when
she watched it she was like I don't
think I've ever seen you that afraid can
I show you what it reminded me tell you
what it reminded me of
I think that because right now and I get
it where you know I'm not going to even
call it an over correction I think
because you know the white men have been
in power for so long I'm just gonna in
in this country how about that I'm gonna
try to be specific and right now because
there's so much pain and anger it's very
uh to go like all white men are bad like
I understand why that might be an
anesthesia to say but I think that as
soon as you know people can move through
the pain of needing that you know
aphorism of all men are then we can go
to the next level of oh my god
um all of the let's just say for now
white men that we're so mad at
like let's um shine a lens on the ones
that are actually trying to use their
privilege or whatever it is or we're not
even trying to they're just doing the
least they can do because there's a lot
of white men out there that in my
opinion are heroes one of them uh I
won't even don't even know his name but
he was uh it's gonna make me cry just
thinking about it
um all of the um
Larry Nasser the guy that molested all
the gymnasts I think it was 50 Olympic
female gymnasts right don't worry don't
worry they're fine they're okay like
they'll be fine but what they what he
did
the thing that makes me the maddest
um because most
women are you know at some point have
something like that happen to them and
sometimes we don't even care sometimes
we really care sometimes it's like oh
this is nothing compared to that last
one or whatever and a lot of boys do too
I mean we don't talk about boys being
molested in the Catholic Church like we
like think it's funny and we like make
jokes about it like it's wild to me and
then we're like why do boys need to you
know like like do all these aggressive
things later well maybe they're in pain
and embarrassed because of what and they
can never talk about it and if they talk
about it people go you pussy who cares
but
so he would um basically molest them
like in front of their parents he'd say
okay she has like a like like if like
that's how to say like okay she's got we
have to fix her alignment from her
pelvic floor like it was like that crazy
so the parents were sometimes in the
room so when he was uh in the courtroom
convicted guilty
one of the dads was there and went for
him
and the security guard the man went
it just stepped out let him go
shit those two men are heroes to me I
watched that video all the time
and it's just like that those that to me
that moment that you know they won't
make a TV show about that necessarily
that moment is like your character in
this someone that is like I'm not gonna
do the thing that benefits me I'm not
gonna do the thing for my ego or my
vanity or my I'm gonna do the right
thing for like everyone in this moment
like I am a protector ultimately you
know what I mean and like that those
those men are out there everywhere all
the time and we just don't talk about
them enough because right now we're like
we don't want to tell stories about
white men it's like well if we don't
find a balance then we're going to erase
or ignore the ones that are
again the pendulum swings swings because
it's like it's like because the people
that do it like you you move through
life hey I got Ponzi uh a decade ago oh
God did you invest with a comedian's
business I invested with a guy that was
if I watched for eight years in a row
continued to bring tremendous returns
for a number of friends of mine
and I you know at first I was like no no
and for eight years in a row I said no
to the overtures of uh uh investing
money with him and I ended up on the
bottom of the pyramid after eight years
of watching people become enriched you
you find yourself going well maybe I'm a
moron here that it has to be legit yeah
going for almost because someone would
have to be yes stopped it something
would have happened by now this guy's
got to be legit and you know and very
sophisticated returns and how about this
things because if you're a good person
you're like well and good people that I
know that that were invested they said
this is because good people don't go
he's not stealing right because only bad
people assume that and I got sucked into
it and as soon as I put my toe in it and
I actually put several toes in it they
were lopped off and it was the FBI uh
I think two or three months after I put
my money into it I received a horrific
email from an FBI agent saying you are
the victim of a Ponzi scheme and the
money has been stolen and we have
arrested
this person
Josh yeah every villain to me is a good
job because it's the most benign name
yeah just Chuck and you're like Josh
isn't gonna steal from all of that Josh
I trust that guy yeah well you know I
always kind of looked at him sideways
frankly and I didn't listen to my
instincts gift of fear the book I just I
didn't listen to my guts and I did for
eight years didn't pass the smell so it
didn't pass that's too much it's too
good to be true no money doesn't come
that's too good to be true it isn't and
I just kept on my guts and and the thing
is you have to understand after I
realized that I I had been a victim in
this the shame
and the guilt that I felt and uh
embarrassment and the embarrassment it
took me a long time to admit out loud
that you know a practical grounded New
England boy got taken by the way an
actor who can smell when other people
are acting this guy
I was fooled and if it can happen to me
man I'm telling you so uh you know I I
learned a tremendous I was humbled in a
lot of ways and I think that life is
humbling you know we don't get out of
here alive you know it's just the truth
of it what breaks me out breaks my heart
about that is this the people that
listen to their gut the most and that
want to move their life with Integrity
then go come on why are you resisting
it's been eight years this is obviously
going to be a way to take care of your
family a way to not have to do bullshit
shows why wouldn't I just why you know
what Mike why are you being such a
stubborn yeah you're just afraid why do
you have to take the hard way all the
time exactly you you know what you've
earned the easy way all of those things
and then you do it and you go God damn
it and then by the way the also the rage
like finding out that this guy and this
was a relatively small Ponzi so this
person here this guy took 65 million
dollars from a bunch of people right but
also the gall that you think you're
going to get away with this you have to
be killed because what else do you think
you could get away with if you think you
could away with that people people's
money like very vulnerable people's
little old ladies all their money you
know but don't you think guys it makes
you go let me ask you a question makes
you go to places that you didn't even
know you were capable do you think if he
was bullied more in school or like
punched in the face a couple times at
bars or something like I just worry that
there's some people out there and this
is just tell me I'm wrong
that we might need to bring back a punch
in the face for certain people every now
and then
you know something I know here's what
I'll say about that okay like I grew up
in Boston in the Boston area not in
Boston Proper because for all the bosses
guy from Boston no because he was from
New York no one from Boston because
they've all been punched in the face
would dare well here's the thing here's
the thing there is
I can only speak for myself
and I know that I
you can't completely get ahead of
yourself too much if you've gotten a
couple of real good beatings in your
life
the punk that thinks he can Swindle you
hasn't been punched in the face enough
well I think anybody who refers to
themselves in the third person
you'd never you did definitely didn't
grow up you know streety in the in the
Boston area for sure because like if you
ever like in Earnest if I can think to
myself if I ever said
I I I'm I'm playing at this now this is
not me saying this this is me pretending
because like if I ever look at my
friends in Boston you're acting quote
please don't act in here dude if I ever
looked at my friends in Earnest as a kid
and went Hey listen if Michael Chiklis
said the the shit the eggs that would
fly at me the the shit that I would go
through this is here guys
you couldn't even think it wouldn't have
been occur that's why I don't hang out
with guys that don't have guy friends
because guy friends humble cool good
ones yeah yeah they play pool with you
you break each other's chops this is how
stand-up comics start sucking they stop
being friends with Comics because Comics
go yeah we know you did The Tonight Show
cool anyway what the fuck yeah good one
yeah they're like oh yeah we didn't
watch it where do you like they keep you
they keep you humble and hungry and and
grounded and real and you don't want to
lose
Contigo is dangerous ego hurts other
people and it hurts you it's dangerous
absolute power corrupts absolutely ABS I
believe that that's a great quote I
forgot who said it but gee I mean Oscar
Wilde takes credit for anything anyone
says so probably him I don't think it
was wild but you know like every quotes
Oscar Wilde you're like I feel like half
of your girlfriends maybe said this
after sex and you're like that's mine
one of my favorites his boyfriends one
about oh you think
yeah right there
okay and then and then I love the idea
that Hollywood was like let's call it
the Oscars after Oscar what I mean it's
like it's all so connected in the
funniest way if you kind of like study
it
um but I do like and this is appropriate
because we are talking about a show
called accused that comes out January
22nd on Fox nailed it
um one of my favorite quotes that Oscar
Wilde might have said
um critics I'm gonna look right this is
what I'm like critics are people that go
to the battlefield where the war has
been won
and they should survivors
wow
okay New York Magazine wow you're
calling out critics by name holy shit I
know which ones are gonna come for me
because of Miami so here's the because
you don't come for Howard you can come
for me but you do not come for Howard
Gordon or we're gonna have a problem
well you know and so Sonic Hoffman the
writer of my episode if you come for
this episode you come for her and then
you have a problem with me so let's just
you know the critics I know it's hard
for you guys to make money right now I
know you're in in a difficult situation
okay but let's just we can work to
because we're on the same team you know
what I mean critics right now are in a
tough spot okay this is where I saw now
we're panicking I could say so many but
don't don't because you guys you guys I
know you need to be
um uh incendiary you need to be
flammable in order to get the clicks you
need but there is a way to do this where
uh you're not
um
uh
200 people worked on this show
it wasn't just us we will be fine
critics I wasn't always fine but when
you uh come for a show uh and go out of
your way to
um go like nah but they there's a blind
spot here and they hired a white guy or
whatever thing you whatever like hot
take you think you're making okay
the other 200 people on this show
they're gonna read it and the only real
their names knowing their names their
pictures they are
you're taking away their pride and if
you take away the pride of a wolf pack
that I am in
we have a problem and it you decided to
go to war with with artists that now do
have a platform I think honestly the
critics will will light up to this I I
think that they'll find this oh for sure
but there might be one or two out there
that are like trying to get clicks
there's no doubt but that listen I know
this for a fact it'll be mild to me
it'll be mine without naming names or or
telling the story specifically I I know
in no uncertain terms that like you say
that we've watched the the the fall of
print and print news and and the move
the shift to
uh to online right and you know in
trying to sell copy they've they've
engaged and people don't I mean when's
last time you watched something because
a Critic made it they you watch it with
your friends become more and more
irrelevant and and not to not that's not
your phone
guys I try to hire critics for TV shows
because I'm like you're a Critic like
you've watched every show come work for
this show with me in my writer's room
because then you can tell me if this
idea has been done well well critiquing
used to actually be an art form in
itself they used to go to school to
learn how and they knew how to critique
something uh from a from a a drama
tragedy standpoint you know where you
look at something in terms of the way
it's structured the way that the
storytelling techniques the you know
when you read something in there and
they're fucking with you about whether
you're bald or not and how could this
woman be attracted to you which I've had
that happen to me and and critics oh
when they do oh yeah
why would like I believe she would be
can I really quick but just let me know
dude can I time out can I time out
it's also
um a movie about someone flying through
the air you moron none of it's real
none of it Jordan Rubin has the best
he goes he was in uh watching Superman
Returns or his goes or fly or super HBO
GO Superman go I don't know but in the
guy in front of him in the screening it
was the scene where Superman was flying
through there and a bullet hit him in
the eye and the eye like stopped it
and then the kid just went no way
holy kid do you know what I'm saying so
it's like it's super Whitney this guy
Chris Hemsworth would never date Whitney
Cummings in a movie how could I believe
this yet he's also holding a hammer that
magically like what the f it's all yeah
really it's all if it's a documentary
disbelief if it said you paid eight
dollars to see something that was fake
and then you saw something that was fake
so critics don't they're not there to be
entertained they're there to pull apart
and find
um what's it called uh well also like I
mean if you want to talk about superhero
stuff and how the critics got it wrong I
mean I listen I'm sorry the Fantastic
Four you got it wrong and there's a
bunch of people in their 30s who wanted
us to have made
um The Dark Knight and that if you were
really an OG Fantastic Four fan like I
was you'd know that this was a very
cheeky the light hey fun critics it
wasn't made for you you dork you want to
be a filmmaker it wasn't me you want to
do what we do and that's okay everybody
does and we're having the most fun and
you're fucking jealous
right now listen to motherfuckers
you guys just come hang out with us and
we will help you do your job right you
want to write the Fantastic Four that's
the Dark Knight and you should and write
that instead of writing a fucking uh
critic piece whatever a criticism piece
that's gonna make all of us not want to
hang out with you just write the script
you want and slip it to us at Coffee
Bean and we will help you
get out of there she said you're an
enemy territory and you're you want to
hang out with us you want to be at the
cool table with us you want us to be
with the cool kids and you can also do
you understand the only reason movies
are profitable is because boys want to
go see men being with women out of their
league because they want to pretend they
can do it
moved those two movies made a half a
billion dollars the guy in my house
right now who's 29 who I'm dating for
some reason it's his favorite movie ever
made he's seen it 14 times and it's a
red flag and I think we have to break up
critics don't matter the critic is the
money the box office but oh my God you
brought me out I went off to the crew
but Michael can I tell you something can
I say something to critics
you guys it's all okay you're hurting
our feelings
yeah and you know it because this
movie's gonna do well with or without
you actually you know what's crazy I'm
gonna say something about the Fantastic
Four yes
you know
I threw myself at that shit and I I I
consider some of the those work on those
shows to be some of the triumphs of my
life because they people do not know
what I was going through when that I was
making that
so the uses of enchantment
how we use stories to inspire people to
heal people to raise people so when you
are playing a superhero in a movie which
I'm going to get this out with
this is the greatest privilege of my
life doing this podcast is meeting
someone that played superheroes in
movies that are also that are
superheroes in real life also because I
know I won't stop okay this is not a
consensual situation no means yes when
it comes okay whatever you're saying
it's the greatest privilege because
millions and millions hundreds of
millions of young boys girls whatever
saw that movie and went oh my God I'm
gonna be that I want to be that guy and
then they're not going to grow up and at
20 find out that you like are a bad
father or a hypocrite so they're not
going to get their heart broken and
they're not going to get their hope
slashed so people hear you talk and they
go oh my God like
that wasn't fake even though it was the
fakest thing ever right because it was a
simulated movie well it's a movie yeah
right it's a movie but you're looking
for the truth in there and anything like
at least I'm looking for this everything
you are you know what I mean they are
there's Role Models out there and I have
someone to look up to and I'm gonna do
what he says and I have a father figure
I I've never claimed to be a perfect
person you know I I I'm I although I do
learn and I move forward and I like to
think that I don't repeat my mistakes
that I keep going that's what a mistake
is you're supposed a mistake is only a
mistake when it becomes a pattern yeah
the idea is you do it once and you go
not doing that again that's a hero yeah
well you know I that's a human and
that's a human who gives a shit and that
gives a shit a lot of humans I I do
really care a lot of humans have a lot
of excuses right now to go I made a
mistake and then I did again and again
because I had a bad childhood and they
you know what they actually can use that
excuse it goes a long way and I'm not
saying it's an excuse for everyone but I
think right now the new sort of um drug
of choice for people that don't want to
change or grow or show up or deal with
discomfort is to say yeah well I had
alcoholic parents and like yeah I grew
up poor it's like and all that's true
but I would like to just remind people
that the worse your your childhood was
or whatever it was the thing that's easy
to blame on look at it as your superhero
origin story instead of as your the J
the prison that's going to keep you from
driving right you know you you you can
Eclipse these things you can go over it
actually makes you stronger than
everyone else so I call it trauma
privilege so when people are like how do
you do all this and you ran through
shows I'm like I grew up in alcoholic
home and was like parents weren't around
because they were working like I just
seems to drive you the things that seem
really hard to a lot of people is really
easy for me things easy for other people
are hard like I can't make um Small Talk
At a dinner party I'm a disaster at it
you know but like I can do things a lot
of people so I think that that looking
at your the things that people
pathologize as limitations you know save
for like being a sociopath and like
killing dogs or throwing cats and fires
as a kid that's not a superhero origin
story that's a like different thing but
adversely well that's sickness right
that's a sick person right and for all
the people like that's a um that's a
different thing yes but all these other
labels and all these other like you know
you know I just I'm gonna bite my tongue
about about that a little bit but I just
think well since we're on you know these
kind of behaviors and sickness and
everything I think something that's very
tragic in the country that's happened
over the you know the last 35 years is
we've closed a lot of mental Health
Facilities across the country
and
you know I know that some of the reasons
for that is because some of those places
were nightmarish in themselves that
there were all these different
nightmarish uh
um stories coming out of those places of
abuse and everything but we're in a
different place now and there's such
oversight in this the possibility to
really affect great change with people
who are ill mentally and and and we have
so much rampant homelessness right now I
think a lot of people can be
you know reintroduced to society if
they're if they're helped and by the way
and the homeless thing and I know a lot
of people uh and I'm not this isn't
identifying with a party but to you know
one of the sort of popular things to do
right now is we've got a homeless
problem a lot of these people served our
country a lot of these people served our
country and like how dare like actually
like kind of how dare you but a lot of
them are also wielding machetes and
going into peace but I just think we're
we're capable of so much more you know
we need to think big we we can't just go
it's either or you know well it's like
the gun issue people say oh we have a
gun problem and other people say we have
a mental health uh problem we have both
right that's right we we can think on
multiple levels we have to think but we
also that's hard people I think that are
have scarcity complex which is most
people that are busy and in fear like
gray is like they're just black and
white it's like guns or no guns and I
think reasonable people go like I think
we can all agree we don't need like the
machine guns right now like talk to
Larry King about that years ago about
it's an either or world right now well
I'm for this and I'm against that it's
much more complicated than that when
Nuance has been lost in in all of our
discourses and Larry's like look I are
you married or you're not I had eight
wives I'm not gonna choose you know I
didn't even name drop Larry okay area
thinking no but I'm serious I'm serious
he's not going marriage or no marriage
keep doing it till it works if no one's
getting hurt and then you know but
that's it this we want to go like we
want our there's Nuance our brains
though that's a lot of bandwidth for our
brains and most people weren't raised to
think like we have to force people to to
think in those terms but I you know what
I I know listen I have this argument
with people about uh what the
programming on television years ago that
you know was moving towards pablum and
it was and I would say hey do you feed
your kids nothing but uh Fruit Loops
they you know but they love Fruit Loops
yeah but you can't just feed your kids
Fruit Loops you know people now want to
be how about this people now want to be
friends with their kids
yeah your kid's not your friend for if
if it can be so I love that I'm close
and friendly with my but with my kids
but my kids also know I'm their parent
right yeah they they know that right you
might not agree with this I had one rule
in my house don't lie to me and you'll
never get in trouble by the way that was
my dad's lie he said to me there were
two things he said never lie to me I
don't care what it is I don't care what
you did exactly I will always forgive
you I will never hurt you but if you
tell me the truth if you don't tell me I
can't protect you I can't help you right
exactly so I would say I never want you
to think the thought dad's gonna kill me
no I'm not because that's what's gonna
make you drive drunk instead of say Dad
can you come get me I'm drunk yeah so he
would say call me John come and get you
call me in a jam I'll come get you and
you actually won't get in trouble if you
tell me the truth right no grounded
nothing and what what is the result of
that I have two incredible
substantive
amazing daughters who come to me and
talk to me who live down the street from
me 29 and 23 we we're together most days
of the week you know and we're close and
we love each other and it's a we have an
incredible bond with each other I also
think most you know if you don't come
from Sports and stuff but it's also
they're so I'm not saying they're lucky
you're both Lucky everyone's lucky like
that being an actor you have this in
being the actor you are this incredible
ability to like actually listen I think
a lot of people hear but don't always
listen and like for me I think that
disciplining anyone that shouldn't even
be the word providing a structure in
which someone can Thrive who doesn't
have all the information yet right who's
trying to figure it out the ability to
really because I think we do we're very
ageist in many ways we talk about racism
and sexism we don't talk about ageism
enough like a 75 year old I'm writing a
movie about it right now love it because
a 75 year old who still says
transvestite like they might just not
know the new term if you tell them that
if you say hey now it's whatever it is
well please can I say this out loud we
don't know what we don't know that's
right and there's a lot that we don't
know I mean with all the places I've
been and all the things that I've
learned in my life there's some my quote
on Twitter is a Socrates quote
uh look it up
um and it's just about you know the
the true wisdom is in knowing we know
nothing and because the fact of the
matter is we are microorganisms on a
larger organism plummeting through the
universe
uh if you look at the most brilliant of
any subject the most brilliant physicist
the most brilliant biologist
and down the line
they will tell you there's so much that
they don't know and that there's yet to
be discovered medicine is called a
practice it's and we all have to have
this Collective humility to say I don't
fucking know I don't know I don't know
I'm learning I'm a work in progress I'm
trying this is my life's Endeavor I'm
Gonna Die Trying that's the way it's
going to go but I can promise you that
I'm gonna keep trying and I'm going to
keep trying to improve and anyone who's
not on board with that those are the
people I have an issue with agree if you
know if you think you know it all and
you have it wired that's when people's
work start to go downhill you said
earlier if you stop being friends with
your your fellow comedians because
you've made it big and you've got the
big compound and you think you're hot
shit that's when that comedian's shit
starts to you know when people go I
loved that actor so much and then they
got famous and like they became a bad
actor like they weren't as good at
acting you're like how's that possible
about that they just didn't have people
around them going dude that's surrounded
by sycophants I didn't believe that read
I'm not laughing you're not as funny as
you think you are right I still have to
keep trying and try looking to improve
and it's like going to the gym if you
don't get to stay you don't get to keep
the muscles if you stop going to the gym
it's everything we can't stay clean on
the shower we took yesterday always but
but what you're saying I think it's it's
it's you know and I'm and you know
Comics like we always are going to in my
what I like to do is voice the person
that is hearing this and being defensive
right and going like wait well how am I
supposed like of course I know things
I'm I'm a I'm a history teacher and
you're like that that's a hard thing to
be right now
because most of the shit in the books is
is very biased what Socrates meant by
what he said was not that people know
nothing right uh literally nothing it's
just comparatively speaking to what
there is to be known but what we do know
is what we've been connected from which
is you did know that that guy was a
thief
but we went well let me look at the
history he's done this so he might we so
I think that what we do know the only
thing we do know and not to add to
Socrates of like does this feel true
like does does it feel like the English
came over and were had a nice fun dinner
with the Native Americans like that
always felt weird to me and I didn't
know like I'm just a kid and I'm
studying history because I this is
what's true and I have to Ace the test
but then you're kind of like Comics we
go this is all just weird because the
photos like because Comics ultimately
were like we just want to be spies and
we just want to be like investigative
reporters and we're like professional
snitches we're like we're the ones that
um don't let shit slide right like so I
was always the one you observe and speak
to it well because then I go hold on
here's the nature of being a comedian so
here's the picture find the funny in it
well I think you just get so committed
to it I I never try to be funny just my
Observer people would laugh when I would
try to be serious and I was like you
know I'm being serious because look the
pilgrims they're in hats and jackets and
loafers and the Native Americans don't
have any shirts on at all so is it's and
it's November so wouldn't they be cold
like this doesn't feel like this adds up
this dinner of Thanksgiving
so like what you know if it was in
November why aren't they wearing why are
they shirtless
so who drew this picture picture is an
odd depiction isn't it but this is what
I'm paying my parents are paying money
and I'm learning this you know so then
that's when your brain starts going wait
a minute what's what this feels real why
you guys decided Rings true it just
feels odd because I because we I
identify with downstairs Downton Abbey
because I'm like someone made this wrote
this book they needed to make money
right someone painted this picture and
they needed the picture
I don't know who who made this picture
who wrote This Book like I just am like
were the one because my question are you
always looking at things and and
questioning why my truth of this really
but like I the answer is I don't know
and maybe none of us know and that's
okay I'm okay with the I know nothing
yeah but well you know what I have a
problem with though is people who have
found themselves in becoming trolls
uh uh and I'm not saying that that's
what you're doing by doing that I'm just
saying that that there are people out
there now that find fault in everything
and I did this as a sort of an
experiment for for my children who have
been pummeled in social media in the
past particularly my oldest because they
grew up when at the Advent I'm
universally beloved on social media so I
don't I can't right no well I I put out
the tweet
um I love puppies purposefully this was
some time ago puppy mill Happy Meal and
someone within minutes I said uh uh is
are they purebreds or or did you get did
you get them from a puppy mill and I was
like Jesus Christ I cannot but it but
and I'm not saying you can't you can't
say something as benign or seemingly
benign as I love puppies without someone
finding fault with it I think that there
are people who have found sort of what
they believe is their voice by just
trolling the internet and finding fault
and that's a that's a sad way to live
your life to that's what my therapist
said function in your existence ages ago
I would go like this person you know I
had a TV show come out I was the star of
a sitcom and the posters were everywhere
and I was just getting I mean like
killed online thank God my mama just had
a stroke thank God crazy thing to say
but I didn't because she wasn't seeing
it I didn't see any of it you know but
to me I've a couple takes on that
because we're about to enter into our TV
show coming out and people are gonna
have a lot of feelings about this yeah
they are and feelings aren't facts I'm
not telling you you like this is oh I
say that to my youngest because she's
she's filled with feelings go on which
is by the way a good thing but it's a
wonderful thing but we just have to say
Okay this is my feeling right now I feel
uncomfortable around this co-worker
uh are they actually okay let me go for
a walk and the trauma brain because this
is the one thing I think that we um
don't spend enough time on is it is it
is the trauma brain and what the trauma
brain does so the trauma brain it feels
true to them when you say the puppy
thing and then I understand what that is
I work again very deep in animal rescue
and most most people that work in animal
rescue were sexually abused or abused in
some way and they project
rightly like this is a voiceless thing
that is against its will being abused
right so they then they go puppies and
puppy mills that's like they're
projecting that on someone who's not
coming from that place at all but then
they go this person has a voice and I
don't and you know what I'm saying so
obligated to so when I and I always make
a I I get very so if someone tweets or
someone that's very famous says like oh
all pit bulls are dangerous I go
like I I get I have to like go cry I
have to go like work through the
feelings that come up because so many
um
children are injured because people
think this way
you know and then they'll like hit a pit
bull around a kid and then the kid the
pit bull gets scared like pitbulls are
bred they're nanny dogs and they're not
even called pitbulls that's not a real
breed who cares I'm just telling you
this is the logic of someone right that
is scared here because they're going
because I've done it when I go oh my God
one of the most famous people in the
world just like said something that my
inner child thinks is Gonna Hurt other
people you know what I mean so it's
coming from a wound and as my therapist
said when I said all these you know when
my sitcom came out you're a whore you're
a con you're not funny and then I was
like so upset by it and she just went
sounds like they're in a lot of pain
right and I was like you got you know
but that's what I've I've said for years
that you know a lot of people but just
because they have thumbs now are able to
go ah right but if you ever turn that
Klee glide back at them
you just blew my mind you know why
what made humans the dominant species
are ascendancy opposable thumbs and now
it's the very thing that's killing us
which is kind of fascinating interesting
you know same thing by the way with
being punched in the face like as as I
was I'm trying so hard to not interrupt
you because I have so much for you it's
not here to interrupt you but also um I
just said like I think more people need
to get punched in the face so you can
look at someone's face right and how
deep set their eye so I already know
that your ancestors weren't fucking
assholes the deeper set your eyes are
the more your ancestors were punched in
the face
oh you would have loved my dad I bet he
was the fucking Earth
I believe a real Greek philosopher if he
raised it he had great catchphrase I
call it catchphrase philosophy
he would say things to me when I was in
despair that would just uh and that's
one of the things that I'm I'm writing
this movie that has to do with the
tremendous generation gap right now in
ageism and everything it's now a year
apart and you can't communicate well
because of you and I think it it it's
been exacerbated by the internet and by
you know because there was cleared uh
derivation between those who weren't
from that era and the irony is that that
machine is the only thing right now that
can that can connect us the most we're
just not using it for that so there's so
much irony in it I can go online and
listen when when when the internet
happened I remember being elated and
going it's the the communication age
we're gonna oh my God it's gonna get
smaller
each other it's going to be so much
better I didn't in my naivete for a
moment think of the misinformation age I
did not think of all them
Asian trolls I didn't take so this is
what Comics do with stuff like and this
is why podcasts are good number one I
was gonna say the amount of wisdom out
there my mom has been in nursing homes
and my dad's been in hospitals uh for
the past 12 years it's fine but I want
to start don't screw it I know I want to
start a podcast that's just interviewing
people in nursing homes like that's
where the fucking wisdom is I want a
podcast that's your dad you know what I
mean we only have podcasts for famous
people but the real wisdom are the
people that don't sign up to do this you
know so I went into nursing homes my to
be clear my dad never lived in a nursing
home my mother did because she suffered
from Alzheimer's for 13 years
so I watched her
completely lose her faculties and it was
the worst thing I've ever witnessed in
my life 13 years she had early onset
Alzheimer's and it took her from 67 to
80 to pass away and
no one deserves that I wouldn't wish
that on my worst enemies worst thing
I've ever seen I'm gonna say it's it's
almost for something like that it's
almost like harder on the the on you
because she might not remember what
happened so in some I was pleading with
my mother to let go the last three years
you know it sounds and my mom was
bleeding my mom was pleading with me to
like help her go I was like my
grandfather did the same thing like
asked my brother and I to shoot him and
can I say I was like can I say something
about that's fascinating we can't do it
you know and but the only gun I can get
is a machine gun yeah she's from Walmart
we went to Walmart and we're looking
it's easy to get he's like he's like you
idiots is America you can't get a
private shotgun it's easier by the way I
feel like I'm downhill it's easier to
get than the medical care I need just go
get the gun down the street talking to
you is almost like downhilling and what
I mean by that is I don't mean it's a
downer I mean you know when you're when
you're a downhill racer you're going 90
and things are going
past you and you're just trying to
fucking hold on
and make it to the bottom without dying
stay tuned for part two
[Music]